Good morning.
It's February already.
I'm back from my hiatus.
I was so burned out doing all
those SAT problems. But now
I'm ready and I will start
doing some physics.
So we had done a bunch of
projectile motion, what
happens you throw something
in the air or
drop it from a cliff.
But now I want to introduce you
to is how do you actually
affect the acceleration
of an object?
And to do that I'm going to
introduce you to Newton's
three laws.
To some degree what we were
doing before was derivative of
what I'm going to do now.
But this is kind of the backbone
of classical physics.
So Newton's three laws.
And you've probably heard
of these before.
Newtow's three laws.
Sometimes they're called
Newton's Laws of Motion.
I've actually looked this up on
the web just to make sure
and see if there's any correct
way of writing it, but every
website seems to have
a different
paraphrase of the laws.
But hopefully, I can give
you an intuitive sense
of what they are.
So the first law is an object
at rest. An object at rest
tends to stay at rest. And
an object in motion
tends to stay in motion.
This is what I learned when I
was a kid and now when I look
at Wikipedia and things, there
are some paraphrases.
And we'll go over those
paraphrases because I think
they're instructive.
Stay in motion.
And you might say, Sal,
this is obvious.
Why does Newton get
so much credit
for stating the obvious?
Obviously, if I look at my sofa
for example, it is an
object at rest and if I keep
staring at it, it tends to
stay at rest. Likewise, when
I look at a car crossing an
intersection-- that's not a red
light, that's crossing an
intersection, it's an
object in motion.
And then, I don't know-- 10
seconds later, it's still
staying in motion and of course,
it will stay in motion
unless you press the
brakes or whatever.
So you might say, well
Sal, this is the most
obvious thing ever.
This doesn't even need
to be written down.
But let's say you were Newton
and you came to me-- it was in
the 17th century.
And you said, Sal, I have
these new laws.
And the first is an object at
rest tends to stay at rest,
and an object in motion tends
to stay in motion.
And I would say Newton, I can
already disprove your law.
Let's say I have an apple and
I'm holding it up at let's say
my-- I'm holding it up with
my arm, so it's roughly my
shoulder level.
So I'm holding an apple.
This is an apple.
Looks like a heart,
but it's an apple.
So I'm holding it with my hand,
I'm drawing my hand.
I don't know if that makes sense
to you, but I'm holding
it with my hand.
And what happens when I
let go of that apple?
So while I'm holding it with
my hand it's an object at
rest, right?
But then when I let
go, what happens?
It falls.
Falls to the ground.
So I'll say, Newton, I just
disproved your first law.
Because this was an object at
rest. And I did nothing to it.
I just let go.
I didn't apply, I didn't push
it, I didn't pull it.
I didn't throw it.
I didn't do anything.
And when I let go it just
fell to the ground.
It started moving without me
doing anything, even though it
was an object at rest.
And then Newton will say, oh,
well that's because there's a
thing called gravity.
And it's the force of gravity.
And I would say, Newton, you
need to start to learn to not
make up things.
Just because you're law doesn't
make sense, you don't
need to make up artificial
forces in the universe.
But anyway, he would
end up being right.
And the way to think about this,
if I did this exact same
experiment while I was in space
and let's just say-- I
was going to say orbit because
it would look like that, but
even orbit is kind of a-- you're
still kind of falling
towards the earth, it's just
you're moving-- well, I won't
go into that.
I'll go into orbit
at another time.
But let's say we were just in
deep space and me and the
apple were just floating
around in space.
Maybe we're stationary.
It's hard to say.
We're floating with
respect to what?
And then, if we're in space and
I let go of this apple,
what happens to the apple?
Nothing.
It's not going to
fall anywhere.
It's not going to move.
And so whenever you think about
Newton's laws-- and
that's why this is so amazing.
He didn't know about space.
He's living in this planet that
everything tends to fall
and things start moving for no
reason because of whatever,
gravity, and the wind
and whatever else.
And he actually theorized that
there could be a place where
there's no forces acting on
objects where if I were to let
go of this apple, it would
just stay where it is.
And similarly, the
object in motion
tends to stay in motion.
And there again I would've
told Newton, well, that
doesn't make sense.
If I were to-- I don't know.
If I were to push a-- well, I
don't know if they had bowling
balls back then.
But if I were to roll a bowling
ball down a-- well
let's say up a hill-- At some
point that bowling ball's
going to slow down.
If I rolled it up a hill,
at some point it's just
going to slow down.
And maybe if I got it right it
would just stop at the top if
I did it perfectly.
And I could say, look, this
was an object in motion.
At some point it stops or it
actually turns back around.
Or even if I were to roll it
this way, at some point it's
just going to stop.
Right The bowling ball's
going to stop.
If I were to push something as
hard as I could, maybe it
travels for a couple of feet,
but then it's going to stop.
And he'll say, oh, well you
know, there's these forces
that you're not realizing
there's a force.
There's the wind resistance in
the bowling ball example.
There's the force of friction
in the example where I just
pushed something.
And I would've said, well
Newton, you're just making up
these forces again.
And this is why this is
so not intuitive.
Because he had to essentially
realize that there were all of
these forces acting on something
when to someone at
that time, you wouldn't have
realized that and you wouldn't
have been able to even conceive
that there's a place
called space, for example,
where these
things wouldn't happen.
If I push something in space,
it will keep going.
It would be an object in motion
and it will keep that
velocity until some other
force acts on it.
So it wasn't that intuitive.
And so a more modern way to
write this is to say that
there is a frame of reference,
there exists a frame of
reference-- and I'll explain
what a frame of reference is.
But there exists a frame of
reference where this is true.
That could be the new way
of saying Newton's
first law of motion.
So what's a frame
of reference?
So everything in physics--
if I'm moving,
moving relative to what?
Moving relative to
the observer?
Moving relative to the earth?
You don't know.
So a frame of reference is what
is the observer doing?
So example: when I'm in space
and I let go of the apple, me
and the apple are kind of in
this-- I am observing the
apple from what I call an
inertial frame of reference.
So this is a frame of reference
actually where
Newton's laws hold.
If I take the apple on earth and
I let go and it drops, the
reason why this first law didn't
hold is because I'm not
really in an inertial
frame of reference.
Because me and the apple are
both constantly being pulled
on by this force
called gravity.
So although it looks like
nothing's going on, me and the
apple are in the same--
nothing's really acting on us.
There is.
There's this force
of acceleration.
Similarly, if I'm in a
car and that car is
accelerating, right?
So let's say the car-- looks
more like a pickup truck, so
I'll go with the pickup truck.
Let's say you have a pair of
dice hanging from your rear
view mirror.
This is the dice right here.
What happens when the
car accelerates?
Well the dice move
back, right?
And so when you're sitting in
the truck itself, it looks
like the dice are just
moving back.
No one's really doing
anything to it.
Let's say the car had no windows
and you would just all
of a sudden mysteriously feel--
well, you'd feel a
little squeezing on your chest
too, but you would also just
see these dice move back.
And you'd say, hey.
Newton's first law
doesn't hold.
And what I would say is well
that's because you're in a
non-inertial frame
of reference.
To someone outside of the truck,
they would see, oh
well, the truck is moving, the
truck is actually accelerating
and that's why the
dice move back.
So in I guess you could say the
horizontal dimension, and
I'm probably just confusing you,
but I want to give you a
really intuitive feel about why
this isn't so intuitive.
In the horizontal direction,
because there are no forces of
gravity or whatever acting in
this direction, and if I'm
outside of the truck, I could
then-- I would be in an
inertial frame of reference
in at least
the horizontal dimension.
I mean we always have gravity
pulling down on us.
But from the outside of the
truck, I could observe that
oh, you know, Newton's law holds
because the whole frame
of reference, this truck is
actually being accelerated.
So me being outside of that, I
would be in an inertial frame
of reference.
Hopefully I haven't confused
you too much.
The way to think about it is
that an inertial frame of
reference is just a frame of
reference where there's no
outside forces acting on the
whole frame of reference.
And a frame of reference
is just what is
the observer doing?
What am I doing?
Am I moving with the object?
Am I being accelerated
with the object?
Or, are neither me nor the
object being acted upon?
And that's the way to
think about it.
Oh, I already ran out of time.
I only got one law done.
So I'll see you in
the next video.